[Music]
okay welcome to puzzlers paradise a very
alliterative class name so normally the
puzzles are easy but you're such a fine
group of of something I think I saw most
of you with the three stooges move you
guys with the jury yeah that's that's
what it was
okay so one of the puzzles is pretty
easy
comparatively and the other ones you
know you got two chances to solve them
and you see the guy named slim running
out that's yeah yeah slim left town okay
you know cuz their chances are slim and
none
yeah and I need to talk about John Nunn
who usually wins the world
puzzle-solving championship a lot lately
yeah okay so puzzles are supposed to be
difficult rawr I'm furious right yeah so
you solved everything right in the kids
class this ain't no kids class so did
somebody bring in Kleenex what yeah and
give some of your brother okay so this
is meat in three in fact normally when I
show puzzles you're like winning a piece
or winning a queen but for you guys that
doesn't really win because you know
cleanup is just like nothing for example
Sasha knows exactly what I'm talking
about
exactly it's literally okay now let me
explain checkmate puzzles to you when I
teach a kid's class especially the one
o'clock class if it's a checkmate puzzle
every move is check otherwise they have
a zero percent chance of solving it if
every move is check they have a 0.1
percent chance of solving it if it's
natan one otherwise it's still zero
okay now unfortunately this is not the
kids class so yeah sorry so that means
the puzzles are difficult that means
first root can't be check we don't do
that in puzzles because that's
ridiculous if you have check in a
checkmate puzzle that
not a checkmate puzzle that's just silly
so you can eliminate every move that's
check because they names answer okay so
this is a mate in three puzzle so I
think if I give you 700 hints you'll get
it now 700 won yeah okay so what you
have to do is imagine yourself
checkmating now if you watch The
Simpsons and if you don't why are you
here there's an episode where Homer
fights for the world championship with
the champion who is named drederick
Tatum but it's supposed to be Mike Tyson
but it's big can't say Mike Tyson anyway
so Moe is his manager because most a
really good manager and he says home
where I'm not going to lie to you you
can Lynn he says what she has to have to
envision how you're going to win and
homers like this and he envisions a
scenario where he deeds Tyson and if
scenario is that his opponent has a
congenital heart defect it had to go to
the hospital before the match so Homer
wins by default that's what you have to
imagine how you're going to win he did
okay so what you have to do is instead
of looking at legal moves which isn't
your strong suit you have to look at
moves that would end up being checkmate
so if you could cheat which is your only
hope where would you put the White Queen
right now by cheating and it's checkmate
you Queens very good that's right Queen
c8 is checkmate that's right yeah good
okay now what's funny about this puzzle
is if you move the Queen to c8 you can
do it in three moves and it's a
maintenance Rapunzel and helpful and
there's actually more than one way to do
it you could go Queen h5 to EA or Queen
h5 to h8 and there's falling ways that I
don't see also do that who know because
that's not me because King AAA or pawn
takes Queen otherwise you're right
except for the two legal moves the black
has okay so the problem is this is a
very funny problem if you play Queen CA
which is made then black is probably
going to try not to get mated unlike
most of your games where you're opposed
League at without care and here's
another question if you try to play
queen CA but you have the black pieces
and your opponent plays queen c8 how are
you going to get out what's black going
to do the next two moves so he has an
escape square so he can get out of queen
c8 mate sorry
well you're giving the move instead of
the idea why'd you play a5 what's your
next move right so he's quiet but he's
still right you play a five then you
play a six and then after Queen ch-check
we have King a seven okay 85 is King a
seven okay now because of that defense
which is a very good defense white only
has one way to win he has to threaten
Queen c8 mate then after a five he has
to change his mind because black stopped
it however I'll tell you another trick
and that might help you I doubt it
if you play Queen takes pawn check
Bishop here that's not mate because of
King a5 you agree according to that guy
over there blacks defense to the three
move checkmate was to play a five which
means the pawn would be on a5 so it
would be checkmate so you have to play
Queen c8 nay but you have to be able to
play Queen a6 check next move that gives
you the answer although it's still too
hard for you but you'll understand the
answer now so that that was helpful so
if you play some normal you know way to
get to see a you can't play Queen a6
check as you move your queen
how can Queen c8 be may but you don't
move your queen right away you
yes but yeah unfortunately if you had
played like this way of mating which
unfortunately a five stops if he plays
King to c7 you could play Queen e8
defending your Bishop with the Queen c8
mate after Queen c4 which is a good idea
now after king c7 you can you can you
can do anything
yeah that's a good idea yeah without
King see something you'd be right
because then you got Queen GA yeah
that's good so you stick it outside the
box he's gonna do this mate and then if
hear you if you a five you could've kept
with your cleaning six
but King c7 suck everything I'll give
you another hint you could solve it if
you were French
we're pulse you gotta make a banner e
but wrong way no such move is legal
there should have five is the square e
six bishops now that's check so that
ain't it yeah and also bishops e6 check
you can't play Queen c8 made this should
age three is the only and move that's
made in three that's correct yeah and
the idea is you want to do that because
I said so that's a good idea
and if the guy runs away then you have
Queen d7 made that battery is a pretty
good battery but you need the Queen in
front of the bishop so you got to put
the bishop back that way the Queen goes
to g4 and now everything is made now
according to this guy over here black
could play a five and then after this we
can escape correct that's why we had to
keep our queen on e2 now after a five
now what is why play White has to switch
Queen a six again if you don't take it
then Queen c8 is mate as discussed
previously and if you take it this shift
see gazes maids because the black pawn
is on a5 stopping the King's mother may
have so the only needs in three is
Bishop age three and the purpose of this
move is to get the Queen to see a via g4
but you're also stopping the defense
that black has because you have Queen a6
check that was probably the second easy
as puzzle so yeah good luck to you now
I'll show you the easiest one so you
feel better right kind of feel good
about yourself okay and this one it's
the easiest one yay this is meeting two
because it says meetin to that's a good
reason right does this come up good on
the video when it's light in here I mean
the lights
do you people can see it what about you
here from Canada can you see okay yeah
yeah well he could see the a file well
that's about it yeah alright this is
meeting two and this is called
overworked so I can solve this very
quickly because I'm overworked you guys
you know laying around all day at the
Chess Club are you stretching your hands
up you're both all right
wait what about your brother with the
wrong answer it's calling him did you
tell him the answer you tell the truth
you are
well this is a checkmate into problem so
you got to try to checkmate them you're
just taking tonight so that's not then
yeah now I'm going to tell you a secret
but don't tell anybody remember when I
told you the first movies never check I
lied
that's why this is the easiest one who
Queen f5 is correct
the knight is overworked its defending
two different checkmates so you play one
of them he has to take it because he has
to eat yo here and then that's mate and
then when he takes it there's all kinds
of checkmate and by all kinds I need one
what is it on e6 checkmate that's right
yeah the night was overworked it was
defending f5 and you 6 it doesn't work
the other way around
because then Queen f5 is in check so you
could only do it one way yeah so Queen
f5 check and if you weren't a puzzle
competition let's say for example in an
alternate universe not in this one
because in this universe you're not the
puzzle competition ok if you're in a
puzzle competition this puzzle wouldn't
be in it because the first move was
Czech
so there was it's a travesty of a
mockery of a sham probably this was a
real game this looks like a game played
in the 1900s by 1200 s it could be game
pleasure 1200 s by 1900 s there anybody
in the world 1900 strength of the Year
1200 probably not probably not now what
an insult to the whole world
ok right now we'll get back to the hard
one this is the hardest one no crying
you can cry ok this is Natan 6 now in
general especially for you at home
the longer the number of moves is the
easier it is when it's mating 10 mating
20 there's like one idea and you have to
figure it out that you just make the
moves well it's like meeting one or two
that's hard because it was amazing sick
and it's White's turn to move now this
kind of position the right idea is
obvious for experience puzzle solver
which is none of you so if you're at
home and you're like one of the top 20
solvers in the world is very easy for
you but you're probably not watching
this video you're probably asleep
because you live in Europe and play with
it okay so the reason this is an easy
puzzle for a top problem solver is it's
obviously zoogs along very obvious
because the puns can't move there's no
legal moves for the points can the black
King move no okay
so only the knight and the Queen can
move but the Queen as you I'm sure
you've noticed by now and that was hard
to say the straight face it's stopping
95 May and 98 May it was wife's move
those rules would be made except they're
not me because the black Queen is
preventing them but if you move your
black Queen could you prevent both of
those maids no so in fact if you move
the knight which has two squares get rid
of those guys that blocks the Queen
Knight here allows 98 mate at night here
allows 95 maid right so this is the
funny puzzle if you could just say I
don't want to move it to your move then
you got no problem that's mean one black
makes the move and you made them okay
unfortunately it's White's move all
white moves allow black to move the
truth hurts
if you move your king the black pawns
can move if you move your H pawn the
King can go to g7 if you move your F
pawn the King can go to g5 it's the
ninth moves you're not threatening these
mates anymore okay and the bishop is
actually doing a good job right now but
I can't tell you why because that would
give you the answer okay now therefore
we have to move our rook if we move our
rook black plays Queen f3 check unless
we play
rookie 3 and that's the answer okay
after rookie 3 Black has one move that
stops these two makes Knight d5 and
Knight g8 mate let's see who can find it
I'll take a nap what's the one move
black can play where neither one of
those is made you with the wrong answer
there's nothing wrong answer he didn't
answer
he got me dang you got me I've never
been tricked like that
somebody find the cat that has his
tongue there it is what's that
96 I said how do you sad night v5 a 98
mate and you allowed 95 mate
what you didn't do nothing you're like
Dennis Larew
oh hey Dennis yeah come on there's a lot
of people in this class you very good
queen G - that defends these two squares
so there's no mate very good okay now we
want to play those mates so yeah not
easy two thirds so in this position
yeah I know the answer and I still
forgot
Gonzalez's okay now I remember
so to threaten nice g8 mate we play
Bishop g4 that threatens a g8 me
you can arguably it does there's two
ways to stop now you eat while you can
check with your queen because that's
temporary I take your queen not good so
how do you stop train he ate me without
giving your Queen away for nothing
there's two possible answers I'll accept
either one you give me Queen a hey yeah
you do yeah I hope he does because Queen
age changes you know that's illegal you
mean here right no okay Queenie eight
that's actually the best move what's the
other move we dig Bishop and now the
Queen
unfortunately stops the black King for
moving is that funny
I thought it was funny okay so Queenie
eight is the best okay now in the
starting position
we played rookie three to stop clean f3
check you were here well you weren't now
I don't care about Queen f3 check
because my bishops on g4 right okay so
now I chill I do it here and I'm like
all right here comes mate
remember I'm going to play these two
mates remember that you remember okay
how does black stop those two mates
you got one move who can do it well
though Queen f3 check does but that's
temporary then you get mated in five
into the six what's the only move that
defends these two squares stopping both
mates you Queen be a very good good job
okay now I want to play Knight d5 me so
how do I stop the Queen from going to d5
Bishop d7 this is why I played rookie 5
because now if you take this is me
because my rips on e5 stopping king of
five smart right okay so now I'm
threatening Knight g5 may you agree I
hope how do you stop 95 million Queen a
a right and now you should find this
move because I already told you the
answer before the puzzle started so you
could find this move I'm just kidding
you weren't here when the puzzle started
so you can't find it I told them before
the puzzle started what the answer was
so they they're like what that was like
five months ago I'll give you a here
this ship we're illegal
I told you Bishop c6 Bishop c6 I'm
guessing I play queen d8 because I just
did so I'll do it again BAM
okay you remember when the puzzle
started and I said if it's black smooth
he has no move but it was White's move
and you're like how does that help me
good job good class we should wear yeah
that's not crazy then I play Queen f3
check band where I'm having deja vu if
you play that what move stops Queen f3
check ok I'm going to stop it to it
you're close you just weren't here when
the puzzle started too bad yeah because
then you would have got it yeah what's
that
what you say riff you for this position
should look familiar to you this is the
starting position except now it's black
smooth yeah black can't move as we
discussed because I has this position
which is the same position and I said if
only it was black smooth but it's
White's move so white goes here here
here here here in outs blacks move the
truth hurts
yeah and now black has to move now
whenever black does 95 is made or 98 is
late I guarantee it the reason is we
can't play Queen be a stopper in Queens
you thought with 25 because the bishops
here we can play Queens u2 or Queen f3
because it's illegal although in my camp
a lot of people made illegal moves so
they could do it yeah that was the
hardest one except for the other ones
that are harder so this is the wrong
problem this position but it's your move
you have to lose a tempest of the other
guys move this happens mainly in King
and pawn end games in a wheelchair but
this is a puzzle usually when there's a
thousand visas on the board
it's nuns lives long because there's a
thousand pieces on the board but here by
threatening different mates and stopping
black from moving yeah now we have mate
next move everybody understand now I'm
kidding ok ok now this is a matin - its
White's turn to move this is a good
puzzle so it's not check this would be a
typical puzzle in a puzzle contest and
this move has a name but it doesn't
happen in real chess it only happens in
puzzles happens in real Grandmaster
games about once every 20 years you see
this idea and it actually has a it has a
name what this idea is so if you do a
lot of puzzles you'll actually see this
a lot then you'll solve it quickly if
you don't do puzzles it's a
you'd ever think of if you do a lot of
puzzles that's a normal idea standard
puzzle idea
so the way to solve puzzles like this
where the first lives that check if it's
a good puzzle when it's mating - doesn't
matter what puzzle it is is happens to
be this one way to solve these is to
find a place where all of your
opponent's pieces are using that place
okay
then if you put a piece in that place
they can't do it there's a name for that
I don't want to tell you the name
because you might have heard of it
you'll solve it you with the right
answer well interference is normal chess
this is a puzzle so it's called
something else
it is interference with a very
complicated interference there's another
name it's called Novotny theme named
after some guy named Novotny okay but in
normal tournament chess you almost never
see it it's just for puzzles what you're
doing is you're taking a square that a
lot of your opponent's pieces need and
you put a piece in there and then if
your opponent takes that piece his
pieces are all blocking each other so
you have to find a square on the board
that all of black's pieces can go to not
all of them but most of them and the
squares actually very useful because
that because black has pieces he's
stopping checkmate if you took away
black's pieces you would find some
checkmates for white but because black
has those pieces there you're stopping a
lot of checkmates what's that before but
I need a chess move he Ford's the right
square so what's the move this should be
for right novotny's theme is usually two
pieces this is three if I like it yeah
and what's good about this move is we
have a very obvious threat and that
threat is nothing see I'm funny
Bishop where b5 this should be five this
is the first move we're done right this
should have four is it make as a king
takes bishop yeah exactly yeah
so this is funny because if you play
Bishop d6 protecting the coupon there
actually is a threat Queen takes fun
made you agree to that leave I agree
chess is hard okay if you defend their
pawn this should be six then you take
away the d6 Square from the black King
the truth hurts so probably taking the
bishop on e4 is a good idea now let's
see with the smartest is mandamus
question how many different ways can
black take the bishop for ya now you
could take it four different ways now I
found this puzzle on the Internet and
this guy was like well there should be
four doesn't work there were a lot of
comments
it's like DK was a king and then the
guys like well this is me he's like oh
now I'm not posting on the internet
about me when I have thirty engines that
could just check I'm not going to say
there's no meat one when I can check an
engine that says matin one but people do
anyway there's no meat you're crazy
what's that work you three mate okay if
you take with the bishop
Misha before because you're blocking the
rook and if you take with the rook
come on save the right square-rigged e5
or queen d5 right yeah it's all me and
that's because you're blocking the
bishop that's likely Novotny seem to
pieces block each other
what about nine takes the ship F for
works against Bishop takes at night
takes cuz you're blocking the rook right
so basically this bishop is defending
this square this work is defending this
square so when you play Bishop e4 no
matter what way you take it you're unde
offending a square and after King takes
you can't block on e fourth one of your
pieces so this is made yeah so if you're
playing a blitz game you would play
Bishop b4 without thinking it's too easy
he's like I would okay and and for an
experience problem solver this is an
easy problem because they're always
doing where they're blocking the two
pieces they're they know about that yeah
so this should be four and if you don't
solve problems a lot forever these are
like impossible because you don't think
of those moves but there's a finite
number of ideas so if you know like the
ten most common you just look for them
okay now this is the next to her main
tonight I'll teach you this one I could
not solve I looked at it for a minute
and I thought I solved it as wrong I was
like okay that's the answer
Ezrin and according to the Internet's
Jennifer shadi did this probably here
although I don't know she lectured on
this so this is the hardest mate in the
one she knows okay and I did look for a
minute I couldn't solve it I guess it's
hard and then I saw the answer and I was
like oh in fact I didn't know why my
answer was wrong I didn't see the move
that black could play I wasn't the only
one
okay so this is Natan one Natan one move
white to play remember White's always
going up and blacks going down etc
you guys were having trouble with Nate
and six I gave you mean one that is nice
of me
especially after a couple of beers we've
eaten one now by the way normally when
I'm playing a grandmaster in a slow game
me are my opponent don't overlook matin
one we avoid that however in the
chess960 tournament in 2011 i checkmated
my opponent they didn't see it they're
like what and they were a grandmaster
what ah I was winning anyway but let me
just mean they're like ah okay
well we won't say who it was but it was
Alexander costing yeah okay so yeah all
right so what's the what's the meat one
weight large wager against whoever
answers first Queen g5 that looks like
that this Queen would take it oh snap
chess is hard I always have a large
wager against the first answer I wonder
if there's another movement that's the
only one now I think that's bowling when
I show you my move that's wrong I want
to see who can refute it who can find
the reason it's wrong now way I don't
feel so dumb if you find it at one
second then I feel done quick Queen
where Queen a3 cracks and he's always
right kids class adult class checkmate
that's the only man there's no other
maid
notice the white rook pins the black
Queen which you did notice because you
play Queen g5 yeah and that's me I
guarantee it
I check things with computers before I
show them to you ah let's see who can
refute my move pawn takes Bishop equals
queen or rook we'll make it a queen
notice that it's checked and you can't
get out of check yeah I didn't see that
Bishop is too far away
yeah this Bishop to b7 darn yeah I
didn't see that is too hard but my
instrument no sense because if my answer
was right then that answers right
I knew something was funny I'm like I
can't both be right
so I must be wrong I didn't know why I
can't see difference going backwards
yeah so Queen 83 is the only answer
there was another puzzle on the internet
that said this is the hardest meeting
one ever but it was wrong I put on a
computer and there was no answer that's
why it was hard you that's okay which
pawn what do you want to make it's
illegal the computer won't let me do it
because this Bishop is pinning it yeah
the truth hurts there's there's a lot of
bishops on white squares so it looks
like these guys are playing bug house
yeah they didn't under promote the
displaying bug house yeah actually you
could promote that pawn against your
queen or a rook
so that has to be wrong because I could
be 10 solutions yeah yeah this is a hard
date one I agree okay and if you like
that mate in one that you'll like this
mate in one
oh this is a meetin one this meeting - I
remember was meeting - and I wrote
meeting one was even harder cuz no
answer so let's replace and we'll write
the number two that's why pencils have
erasers
so this puzzle I know the answer and I
was like why isn't this the answer - and
then I was like oh okay yeah so I'm
actually going to ask you that well you
solve it and I was like when we see the
right answer I'm going to ask you I
another movies is the right answer and
see if you got it like I did which I
didn't get so white mates into moons
remember the first move is in track
because it never is
now I think it's pretty obvious since
we're near the end of class that this is
a super strong problem I mean even you
guys do that and what I mean is there's
a lot of situations where you can see
black moving and getting maded for
example I would like to play Knight b3
mate but black has a knight defending
that therefore if last night moves I
have 9 d3 mate also I would like to play
rook takes pawn me in case your bishop
moves also I would like to play Queen g1
me in case your bishop moves you see
what I mean okay and what I mean is
Queens you want isn't me if the rook
blocks but rook takes e4 is me if the
bishop defends the pawn which means is
blocking the rook you see what I'm
saying
no I tried so for example if we play
here defending Riki for me then Queen g1
is me because the black Bishop is
blocking the black rook if the bishop
goes to f3 defending the e pawn queen g1
is made if the bishop moves and doesn't
defend the e pawn and rook takes pawn is
me now the bishop can't move because of
the mate I just showed you
nice can't move because the knight be
free mate the pawn can't move because it
can't move rook can't move because it's
pinned ok well that's a good answer not
the right one so therefore if there was
black to move here what do you think he
would do he make an illegal move his
work spin I just said that this should
have three less Queen g1 Lee which I
just explained but I just gave a long
explanation about that either e5a refix
very good now the problem with e6 is it
blocks the rook and it locks the bishop
so Queen d7 is made which is funny
because Queen d7 is not even legal but
after
it stops to bless it stops to things and
what that's a legal move the job better
than most in class now my question is
what's black going to do here pretend
it's black smooth he filed right after
e5 there's no main okay so we have to
make a move we're after a five we do
have a maid you can't you can't be
taking something in a puzzle terrible
yeah
now the problem with Rick HC these rooks
are genius
this works defending that you don't want
to understand that you don't want the
black King coming in here so don't move
that rook you don't want to move this
truck because as I explained three or
four times
we're playing riff takes you four
million so if you play rook takes h5 I
can move my bishop
if you don't play Rick takes h5 you'll
play rook taking for me now you can't do
that because the Queen's pinning the
rook so if you unpinned the rook I'll
put you in check and you won't meet me
in two moves if I put you in Jack now I
mean you don't ring me at home okay now
instead of figuring out what you want to
do which is your usual problem figure
out which piece I said nothing about
which piece I didn't talk about that's
doing nothing maybe that's the piece you
should move the pieces that are doing
something o move those those are doing
something which piece have I not talked
about at all the white watch white piece
yeah in fact I didn't really talk about
either bishop yeah okay so obviously the
district line AAA that's stopping the
King from going here the bishop on c7 is
stopping the King from going there but
if we move either bishop we have a lot
of moves that keep those squares under
control we're still okay now that's
what's funny is if you play e5 I haven't
moved this check that isn't me but it is
me because you play d5 and then
movies this should be six this should be
six is me except you play king e5 but if
your puns on e5
you don't play king e5 but hold on I'm
not done but if you play e5 you're not
pinning the rook anymore you agree so
this should be six does it make because
you take it so you make a move where he
can't take it
you Bishop c6 right so that doesn't do
anything bad it just keeps White's
advantages but now after E 5 we have
made because the rook can't take the
bishop we're blocking the rook and at
first I was like why is this ship c6
Wiggin out there should be seven what's
the difference and the difference is
after a five this should be six check I
can take it I need to block that rook so
I play Bishop c6 and that stops a five
and he five was the only move I was
worried about and e5 hurts black because
it's thoughts flashed from play King e5
right and that way you have made and in
fact missed a trick most of you but not
really if it was wife's move here White
has nothing black is ins live long if
it's White's move there's no maid but II
five allows this should be six mate
there should be six inmates as a king e5
everybody agrees okay
that's why puzzles are difficult because
a lot of them are Zuzu on you make a
move and you have no threat but all of
your opponent's to lose lose okay and
when you play tournaments you guys do
that all the time okay and we have a
name for that in regular chest
it's called domination you make a move
and I'm going all right here move and
I'll tell you when you do this you've
all done it before now not all of you
most of you you actually have done it
you didn't know it when you have king
and rook versus King and that's it
probably usually have the king but you
could have the rook maybe you're talked
about at apply okay so you have king and
rook versus king you can't win unless
your opponent
takes a losing move so you have to make
a waiting move sometimes then they walk
into me
if it was always your move you would
never win and king and rook versus King
you're putting your punishments live
long usually more than once and you're
like ah how you have to move either
opposed Kings or run to the corner if
your opponent didn't have to move
you wouldn't linking in reverses King
because your opponent would just keep
this king where it is if you oppose king
they move away but if you make a waiting
move with a rook which is the way to win
now your opponent has to walk into me
one way or the other and so those are
the live as long as you guys do a lot is
king and rook versus king you can do a
lot as look as long as the King and pawn
versus King but probably law if you
don't have that experience from - and
when you have King and pawn versus King
there's a lot of positions where if it's
your move it to draw and if you're at
your opponent's move they have to make a
bad move and lose because in lives one
and so this is one of those positions
the difference is there's a lot of
pieces on the board so sorry
that's like puzzle time right and I'll
tell you puzzle story before we end
class when I get puzzles to my students
normally they're really easy like for me
they're really easy to solve in one or
two seconds they saw them eventually
usually they're like eh I solved it good
when I had puzzles when I was working
with Grandmaster Qaeda knov it would
take me like an hour to solve each
puzzle and I wasn't sure if I was right
even when I was done I was like if
that's right it wasn't made it was like
get a good position and one puzzle I
found particularly difficult and I
solved it like an hour in 10 minutes and
there's two funny things about that
answer when I was done cried nan said
that's right I don't know if I was right
but he said I was right and I said that
puzzle was hard when you were a student
how did you do on it and he opened his
old notebook like you guys have old
notebooks at chef and he said oh I
looked at it for two hours and wrote no
solution ok and then I went to my local
local chess club but in Arbor Michigan
and the players there were 2020
100 I showed them the puzzle I showed
them the answer and when I was done they
were like what why is that the answer so
yeah so some puzzles are really hard
even when you solving you know if you're
right these are checked made puzzles so
if you turn the engine on it solves them
in 1 millionth of one second that mate
in six as soon as I turn the engine on
it's solved no problem okay now some
puzzles the engine can't solve but
they're not checkmate puzzles they're
likewise to play and draw and the final
position is some positional draw that
computers don't understand yet where
it's like blocks off with somebody's up
a queen or something and then you don't
know you know you can't win I understand
the computers like mocha Queen yes and
it says plus nine but you know it's a
draw well not that you guys know what's
a draw but yeah you can see that it's a
draw when it's a checkmate puzzle
engines are very helpful so we take
positions that are puzzles from a
hundred years ago 50 years ago 150 years
ago and put them in the engine and see
if the guys right and maybe 10 to 15% of
puzzles that are old the answer is not
right either the answer doesn't work or
there's another answer more life that is
another answer now the machine just
solved it in a second it's like oh
maintenance that has automating sex like
to play and win here's another one to
take ten extra moves and you're like oh
yeah so now when we have puzzles and
they're published since everybody has
engines everywhere and they're free or
you could buy them that's a better idea
and it says the free ones actually are
free obviously if they weren't free I
would steal them but they are free for
example what's the best free engine
yes oxygen is free you'll have to steal
it terrible that makes my life like
life's worth living because I can't
steal it
but if I if it wasn't free I would still
have it then I wouldn't pay but it's
free so yeah and chess space is also
free I mean buy it from the Chess Club
yeah don't mat that out or unless we
want to go to jail
yeah so basically all chess software you
can buy if you can make puzzles and you
can check and make sure there's one
answer
and when I do camps for really strong
kids mm Plus which I do all the time one
of the exercises I had to do is to
invent a puzzle I'm like 15 minutes make
a puzzle and I tell them what it is and
the last one I did was meet in 3 they
had to make of eight and three and then
we would vote on whose was the best and
then half the time it wasn't me or there
were seven answers and then sometimes
well yeah there's mate in three there's
one answer and if it's really really
really easy we would like take art like
if it's like maton three for a beginner
we're like you're 2,200 you made a mate
and three that takes one millionths of a
second and solve come on but if you're
not used to making puzzles are solving
them it's hard to do something like that
right so the question is the guy who
invented this puzzle how did he do it
how did he make a meeting - and this is
the answer what's that he figures up
some kind of mate and then pins every
piece that makes them can't move yeah
it's not easy yeah but people who just
make puzzles they're pretty good now one
of the most famous American puzzle
makers who doesn't make puzzles anymore
but he used to is the professor Noam L
keys all your favorite person okay no
mal Kees is the youngest person in
history to the Harvard professor and
anything and he was 2,300 chef in quit
chest and he's good as being a Harvard
professor he became a full professor at
age 26 like most of you what you guys
will do Dave and he got his PhD at
Harvard when he was 20 so that's how he
rolled okay and he would solve and
invent puzzles like this that's one
thing he did in his spare time but now
he too busy doing professor okay but he
was a great problem composer in the US
so you can see he was a smart guy and he
made puzzles like this I've made puzzles
but you don't want to see them because
they never come to my class again like
that's a puzzle what's wrong with you
it's worse puzzle ever and some of the
kids puzzles that make them do are very
funny
there's like
simple bonds and you know just to stop
the kings of living so it's funny
they're like how do I get the king now
when you see a good puzzle a good one
like this one if you asked me why is
that piece there I'll tell you every
piece has a reason there's not like just
put random pieces on the boards that
confuse you
they're all there they have to be there
if you take them off there ain't no
answer that's a good puzzle when the
kids make the puzzles there's like seven
random pieces on the board so they can
like trick you like how high you thought
that was being to but it's not but here
everything has a reason this rook is
stopping III this where it goes to e4
this queen is pinning the rook
there's Queen g1 mate there's Knight b3
mate this pawn is stopping King c5 this
pawn is stopping Kings from three this
pawn is defending the d3 pawn in case
like the dishes of the d3 f3 for example
or torture h3 and these bishops are
obviously doing something I'm not sure
why the White King is where it is I
don't think it helps with checkmate but
I think it had to go somewhere and I
think because the White King is there an
answer that you gave like Queen's a g4
like now I have work a6 check so it's
making it's making you not able to move
your queen so it's like what's the king
there so he can get checked and then one
of the answers doesn't work I think
that's why it's there but I'm not sure
lights there and the other piece it's
clearly why it's there otherwise doesn't
make any sense this plums here defending
the bishop this Knight is stopping night
mate this is a good puzzle
it's matin - there's only one answer
there's a lot of pins and if you were
just playing a random tournament game
you would never think of Bishop c6
because I doesn't make any sense so
that's why it's a puzzle
ergo puzzle time or what's it called
yeah puzzlers paradise I'm kidding all
right and again in my usual spiel that's
the one thing he got right a class
dismissed
you
[Music]